flowers and candles at Krefeld zoo more
than 30 animals were burned to death
here after a fire broke out at the ape
house among the dead animals are highly
endangered apes like orangutans from
Borneo lowland gorillas from Central
Africa and chimpanzees from West Africa
become a total of eight apes were killed
amongst them masa Europe's oldest
gorilla he was 48 years old the fire in
the ape house broke out shortly after
midnight the house was also home to
fruit bats and birds they were all
killed in the blaze but two chimpanzees
survived police say the fire was caused
by a sky lantern launched for New Year
the owner contacted authorities soon
after the fire reportedly unaware that
the sky lanterns are banned almost
everywhere in Germany including where
the zoo is located
yeah the people wanted to set off these
lanterns with good wishes and of course
they didn't think that could lead to
what happened here I must say I think
it's courageous of them to go to the
police and say yes we're responsible I
find it extremely decent and they have
my respect while Krefeld zoo now remains
closed investigations into how the fire
spread are underway
ok let's bring in DW correspondent Donna
reg of who's in the clear fed at the zoo
Donna out authorities are saying a
mother her two adult daughters are
responsible for the fire what's likely
to happen to them now yes that's right
well what we know so far like was
previously shown in the report is that
they have turned themselves into police
now they are potentially going to be
charged with a negligent arson and that
type of charge could carry a sentence of
up to 5 years in prison but they could
also face just a fine instead this these
details we'll learn more about them as
the day progresses people have been
bringing candles and flowers clearly
this is something that's really affected
people what is the zoo doing to manage
this tragedy
yeah it's correct you can see right here
behind me that people came in to light
candles lay flowers passers-by who mice
talked to earlier even said that they
almost feel like the monkeys and the
Apes and the animals in the zoo were
almost their relatives here in this town
and that's why they feel like this
disaster is very much very close to
their their hearts we know that the zoo
remains closed and it allows the people
to come here and pray and like candles
and bring their flowers we also know
that the zoo might take further actions
and investigate whether some materials
from which the roof was built maybe they
were too flammable or dangerous and the
zoo will keep on
updating further on today - apes
apparently survived the fire do we know
what's going to happen to them well we
don't know what's going to happen to
them yet but we do know that at least
their situation is stable and good and
the zoo management is very satisfied
with at least the way that these monkeys
survived and we are hoping for their
full recovery very quickly all right
Donna reg of include food thanks so much